[Music]  do we have years I helped you you left  me in a black hole of rage and  conversion I want us simple a task force  of the most dangerous people they're bad  guys worst of the worst hi boy  Mamma Mia Mamma Mia Mia let me go speed  I love me  y'all Joker's must be crazy take action  to the next level with explosive  behind-the-scenes content and new  footage you didn't see in theaters about  was gangster  do it  don't forget we're the bad guys  it's the end of the world have a drink  with us  you whiskey how are you hot stuff water  that's a good idea  Suicide Squad extended cut on the  digital HD now or blu-ray December 13  spread - were y'all Jokers must be crazy  [Music]  what